raymond la faune bonjour oui bonjour
bienvenue dans la matinale de rtl france
le pass sanitaires on lisait obligatoire
dès aujourd'hui notamment dans la
restauration votre secteur de travail
qu'est ce qui est mis en place
concrètement aujourd'hui ça va se passer
comment un contrôle à chaque prise de
service
à dire que nous aurons nous aurons à
scanner les les qr codes pour chaque
personnel entrant dans notre
établissement pour une pour une durée du
service est valable à chaque fois chaque
jour nous devrons faire ça alors il se
pose un gros problème car même puisque
comme vous le savez nous étions déjà des
métiers de tension et nous avons une
grosse haussier avec tout ce qui est
saisonnier ou les salariés ne veulent
pas se faire vacciner puisque c'est
souvent un deuxième emploi ou une
deuxième activité de sur leur salaire
c'est à dire que là vous n'avez plus
pour le mois de septembre vous n'avez
pas de suffisamment de salariés
embauchés dans la restauration et en
plus s'ajoute ce pas sanitaire qui
devient obligatoire donc le recrutement
est très très compliqué aujourd'hui
c'est ce que vous dites c'est ça c'est
ça si vous voulez ce qu'ils vont arrêter
dans notre branche parce qu'ils ne
doivent pas se faire vacciner on pourra
pas les remplacer puisqu'il reste bonne
au mal un mois un mois et demi de saison
d'été est donc ça veut dire que des
entreprises vont être obligés comme on
l'a vu à repasser en avant a emporté
avec moins de salariés ou à fermer leur
établissement
faute de scénario alors quand vous
échanger avec vos collègues les autres
restaurateurs vos salariés qu'est ce
qu'il vous lisez ce qu'ils sont plutôt
favorables à cette mesure comment est-ce
qu'elle ait reçu
alors dans les salariés qui sont on va
dire à l'année c'est ça à sa peu près
parce qu'on a eu ça fait déjà longtemps
où on s'applique à leur expliquer que ça
va être obligatoire que cdc bien
obligatoire
donc si vous voulez on va dire qu'on va
régler le problème
il y aura en perdra mais quelques
salariés mais pas la majorité par contre
par contre qu'un cdd
comment dire des établissements qui sont
ouverts six mois sur l'année eux ils
vont perdre beaucoup parce que leurs
salariés se disent tu as mois de la fin
de leur contrat ils vont pas se faire
vacciner si l'on n'en parle mais ces
pertes la allié au pass sanitaire qu'est
ce que vous attendez du gouvernement on
sait que le quoi qu'il en coûte a été
donc c'est la fin à partir de demain
vous souhaitez tout de même qu'ils aient
une étude au cas par cas pour dans la
restauration
on voudrait que soit pris en compte la
baisse du chiffre d'affaires liée à ce
se passe
avec d'autres personnels pour soi si on
est obligés de refuser des clients qu'il
y an soit tenu compte alors que je
comprends parfaitement que les
restaurants fermés ça aussi un autre
souci mais celui qui essaye de
travailler qui arrivent pas faire son
chiffre il faudrait que les et de
perdurer quelle sera l'attitude à
adopter avec un salarié qui ne veut pas
se faire vacciner
dans un premier temps on va lui donner
ses congés ses rtt tout ce qu il a droit
dans un premier temps deuxième temps
nous allons le mettre en congé sans
solde pendant une durée de 15 jours au
bout de quinze jours on va voir quelle
est sa décision s'ils maintiennent
son anti vaccins ou ou s'il veut bien se
faire vacciner on pourra remettre une
durée de 15 jours et puis après ben il
faudra penser à un licenciement le
convoquer et le licencier pour
il ne restait une rapide dans le cadre
de nos salariés un protocole sanitaire
qui était déjà contraignant et qui
étaient mises en place dans les
restaurants est ce que ça ne suffisait
pas finalement
c'est un peu incompréhensible
il ya toute une partie qui est à
l'extérieur où c'est déjà compliqué à
expliquer la clientèle et qu'il faut
quand même un passage ni terre à
l'intérieur autant content vous les
clients
l'extérieur a été très compliqué et
encore plus compliqué à expliquer à
notre personnel que celui qui en est en
cuisine ou réponse doit avoir le pass
sanitaire c'est c'est surprenant etc on
a du mal à le faire passer avec notre
personnel en tout cas merci beaucoup
raymond la faune d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin je le rappelle vous
êtes maître restaurateur à auzon
également président de l'union des
métiers de et des industries de
l'hôtellerie et la restauration en
ardèche